Here are the solutions for 10, 1, and 9x squared minus 36x plus 37. Great
solving, if you got all three of these correct. Now, if you only got one or two
of these right, that's okay, too. These are not the easiest problems, and I'm
sure you'll get it with more practice. To find f of g of 1, we first need to
find the g of 1. So, when 1 is the input for g, we should get an output of
negative 2. We get that simply by letting x equal positive 1. So, now, that we
know g of 1 equals negative 2, we just need to find f of negative 2. We use
negative 2 as the input for f. If we let x equal negative 2 for this function,
here and here, then we can see that we'll get a total sum of 10. Negative 2
squared is positive 4. Negative 2 times negative 2 is positive 4, which makes
8, plus another 2 equals 10. This is how we solve the first problem. And we can
use the same approach to tackle this problem, f of g of 2. Letting the x value
equal 2 here, we get a g of 2 equal to 1. So we know that the output of g is 1
when x equals 2, so I can replace this g of 2 with the value 1. Now we just
need to find f of 1. I'm letting the output of g when x equals 2, now be the
input for f. Negative 2 and positive 2 sum to zero. So then I just have 1
squared, which equals positive 1. Now, we've done two calculations for f of g.
But it would be so much nicer and easier if we just had one function to work
with. An f of g of x function. So to find this function, we simply take g of x,
and we plug it in anywhere we see an x and f. So notice that here and here,
I've left spots for the x. We have something squared, minus 2 times something,
plus 2. We're going to take g of x, which is 3x minus 5, and use that as our
input. This is how we find a composition f of g of x. We have x as our
variable, and we finding the output by plugging in g of x into this function.
Squaring this binomial, we get 9x squared minus 30x plus 25. Then we'll
distribute this negative 2 to get negative 6x plus 10, and a positive 2 on the
end. There's no like terms with 9x squared, so I'll just list that here. Then
we'll combine the like terms of negative 30x and negative 6x to get negative
36x. And finally, we'll add 25, 10, and 2, to get positive 37. This is how we
get our entire composite function.